je tomberai plus jamais à moi tu jures
web masi crash
ça marche pas si tu cache pas on vivait
ensemble du faire ensemble
à part baiser a créé tout un ensemble
bien y aller la coloc là
[Musique]
à paris café suis désolé je te jeter pas
fait mal quand tu me couvre mec j'ai pas
envie que cette fille avec qui j'ai
couché deux fois bien puisque le bordel
dans notre amitié voilà c'est plus juste
du cul aux normes quoi et webone sommes
contents ça fait des semaines qui
découchent oh mais c'est bien ça que tu
es une vie sexuelle épanouie c'est
malheureusement fils avec christophe
nous on expérimente région par d'autres
choses nt1 car je désignerai en boîte
qui fait quoi tu parles acquis à
personne l'aftam est pas de sept siècles
et du coup je suis allé à qui tu es
[Musique]
bon alors on choisit qui julie n'est
fait ni pourquoi
qu'est ce que t'as foutu chemin sans
jeter à l'achat était là depuis le
départ comme ça je fais du breakdance et
l'a300 je sais
tu as une tête elle est horrible